So the last time we tried to film chlorine
experiments we
found that the chlorine cylinder itself had
a slight
problem, it was seized here. But the Stig
has acquired
another cylinder of chlorine. So you know
what this
means, it means that we feel duty-bound to
increase the
intensity of our chlorine video and show you
some
chemistry with chlorine.
Chlorine is an element that many people have
heard of.
It’s a greenish-yellow gas which consists
of, the gas
consists of two chlorine atoms bonded together
so it’s
Cl2 and it’s much heavier than air.
Incredibly reactive, incredibly poisonous,
not a very nice
compound at all. Ok so Neil is about to open
the cylinder
of chlorine to allow some of the chlorine
gas to leak
through the pipe into the, to the flask in
the fume hood.
Chlorine sits in the right-hand side of the
periodic table
in the halogens in group, well, some people
say seven,
some people say seventeen. Really what that
says is
that chlorine wants another electron to get
that noble
gas configuration and it will move heaven
and earth to
get that electron!
So during the First World War it was used
as a chemical
weapon. The gas could spread across the battlefields
and when it came to the trenches, which were
holes in
the ground, it would fall into the trenches
and fill them
up.
You can see the yellow colour against the
white
background on the paper, so now we’re starting
to fill
that flask with chlorine; it’s quite dense,
so it will stick
to the bottom of the flask it’s not like
a light gas like
hydrogen or helium, it won’t come upwards.
So now you
can see the colour in that chlorine is really
quite intense.
It wasn’t a terribly good weapon because
it could quite
easily, if the wind changed direction, it
could blow the
gas back to the people who were letting it
out.
So we’ll just put a stopper in to contain
the gas while we
prepare the rest of the experiment.
Chlorine is quite corrosive, it reacts with
water to make
an acid, HCl, hydrochloric acid which can
attack people’s
lungs. The lungs generate fluid, they fill
up with fluid and
quickly the person drowns in their own fluid.
It also
corrodes things very easily so all the metal
fittings on
people’s battle dress, the brass buttons,
brass buckles,
all went green as well. But it’s not a terribly
effective
weapon but when people weren’t expecting
any sort of
chemical weapon it must have been terrifying.
Ok so we have a small amount of aluminium
here which
we put on the end of a wire. We’re gonna
heat the
aluminium in that flame and then we’re gonna
put the
hot aluminium into the flask of chlorine,
then hopefully
we’ll see, the chlorine will react with
the aluminium and
we’ll get very rapid formation of aluminium
trichloride,
AlCl3.
The British Army created whole regiments of
gas
soldiers who were all trained chemists, who
were sent
out to handle these cylinders of gas. And
on the German
side in the First World War, Fritz Haber,
the inventor of
the Haber process to make ammonia became very
keen
on chemical weapons and he was the chief proponent.
His wife was really furious about this and
in fact shot
herself with his revolver, killed herself,
the day before
he was due to go back to the front. And he,
it was said
that this was because she objected to his
work on
chemical weapons. Though at the same time
there were
rumours that he was having an affair with
another
woman, so there may have been other factors
at play as
well.
So, let’s heat up our aluminium. Ok, so
it’s nice and
warm, all over. And then we’ll drop it or
add it into the
chlorine glass. Now instantly we are seeing
aluminium
trichloride coming out of the top and reacting
with
moisture in the air. So now you can see the
reaction is
getting very intense and we are seeing a flame
in the
bottom. So the aluminium is being consumed
as it’s
reacting, oxidising strongly in that chlorine-rich
air.
Chlorine is found all over the world, the
sea contains
sodium chloride, and there are huge deposits
of sodium
chloride in salt lakes where lakes have dried
out, such
as in some parts of the States, where you,
United
States, where you have salt lakes where people
can
race cars and things across the flat surface
and in other
parts of the world.
All of the aluminium has been consumed now
by the
chlorine: a very, very rapid reaction.
There are many areas, such as in the north
of England,
in the county of Cheshire and also in Salzburg
in Austria,
where there are prehistoric deposits of salt
from
prehistoric salt lakes, which can now be mined
really
quite easily, and there, so salt and chlorine
is a very
common element. It’s made from sodium chloride
solution by electrolysis, by passing an electric
current,
and it’s a very energy intensive process.
One percent of
the UK’s electricity was used, at one time,
for making
chlorine from sodium chloride, and the chlorine
is used
particularly for making the plastic PVC.
While we got chlorine here, we thought we’d
do a couple
of reactions. So we’ve got some chlorine
in this flask
and you can see the nice yellow colour and
I thought
what we’d try and do now is do a competition
reaction
again or a reaction with iron. So now the
iron, we’re
gonna heat the iron, this is iron wool which
you might
use for treating wood, and we’re gonna heat
that until
it’s warm and put it in the chlorine, the
chlorine will
oxidise it to iron chloride.
Chlorine will react with all sorts of metals.
You can make
salt by burning the metal sodium in chlorine,
and if you
put in other metals like aluminium or iron
they will also
react. Aluminium reacts to form aluminium
trichloride
which is the salt of aluminium and iron will
similarly
react to form iron chloride, and most metals
but not all
of them will react with chlorine: lead will
not for
example. But it is really quite a reactive
gas.
So really rapid reaction there as the hot
iron starts to
react with the chlorine to form iron chloride.
Very, very
exothermic again and I think, yes this is
very hot, we
might have to move it off the paper.
So what happens in all of these reactions
is that the
chlorine removes an electron from the metal
to make
the chloride ion Cl-, and the chloride ion
is perfectly
innocuous, you can drink, you can eat chloride,
whereas
chlorine itself is very poisonous.
Oh it’s warm, it’s not too hot to touch
its like picking up
a mug of warm tea or warm coffee. But you
can see
again the products of the chemical reaction
have
precipitated out across the flask, and now
if I remove
the…wire again I can see that all of the
iron has been
consumed again instantly. The moment that
it got into
that chlorine-rich flask; very, very rapid
reaction, very,
very reactive with chlorine.